the president we are in an extraordinary
crossroads in American history both from
a moral perspective as well as an
economic perspective and the reality is
today as I think most Americans
understand is that the middle class of
our country is collapsing over the last
10 years median family income has gone
down by twenty-five hundred dollars
millions of Americans who have lost
their job secured new jobs at
substantially lower pay young the
workers finding it very very hard to get
a job at a livable wage furthermore mr.
president what we don't talk about
terribly often here on the floor of the
Senate or certainly in the corporate
media is the rather unfortunate reality
that in the United States we have the
most unequal distribution of income and
of wealth of any major country on Earth
today the top 1% of earners makes
twenty-three percent of all income top
1% earns twenty-three percent of every
dollar and that is more than the bottom
fifty percent top 1% makes more money
than the bottom fifty percent the
percentage of income going to the top 1%
mr. president has nearly tripled nearly
tripled since the 1970s between 1980 and
2005 eighty percent eighty percent of
all new income in america went to the
top 1% today when we talk about
distribution of wealth not income the
numbers are frankly beyond belief today
in America if you can believe it the
wealthiest 400 Americans 400 Americans a
very small number out of a nation of
over 300 million
people own more wealth than the bottom
150 million Americans 400 150 and that
gap between the very very rich and
everybody else is growing wider mr.
president I don't have to describe
economically what's going on in this
country because almost everybody
understands it real unemployment today
is not eight point nine percent it's
closer to sixteen percent today in
America 50 million people have no health
insurance today in America our seniors
and disabled vets understand that they
have not received a Social Security
koehler in three years so what we start
with mr. president when we look at
America today is a middle class which is
disappearing poverty which is increasing
and the people on top doing phenomenally
well now given that reality one might
think that the Congress would be
actively involved in trying to protect
the middle class and working families
and lower-income people but if one
believed that one would be sorely
mistaken mr. president just last
december four months ago congress passed
legislation to provide huge tax breaks
for millionaires and billionaires by
extending the Bush tax cuts to the top
two percent and by even more by lowering
the estate tax for the top three tenths
of one percent so at a time when the
people on top already doing phenomenally
well what Congress did against my vote
in December was make the wealthiest
people even wealthier so four months ago
after giving huge tax breaks to
millionaires and billionaires growing
the deficit our
publican friends and some Democrats come
back and they say well you know now we
have a real deficit problem we made the
problem worse in December so now we
really have got to deal with the deficit
and we're going to do it by making
devastating cuts to programs that low
and moderate income Americans
desperately depend upon what were you
looking at mr. president is the Robin
Hood principle in Reverse we are taking
from working families who are struggling
to survive taking hundreds of billions
of dollars and giving it to millionaires
and billionaires in my view this is
grossly immoral and it is also very very
bad economics let me just touch on some
of the cuts that are coming down the
pike in this the 2011 budget at a time
of soaring fuel prices in the state of
Vermont and I'm sure in Minnesota a lot
of people heat with oil cost was going
up the low income home energy assistance
program liheap would be cut by 390
million dollars in Vermont many of the
people who use the LIHEAP program a
low-income senior citizens so we give
tax breaks to billionaires and we go
after low-income senior citizens as a
sorry you may have to go cold at a time
when the cost of college education is
getting unaffordable for many many low
and moderate income families in this
country hundreds of thousands of young
people have given up their college dream
because of the high cost of college Pell
grants would be reduced by an estimated
thirty five billion over ten years
including a nearly 500 million dollar
cut this year and Pell grants are the
major source of federal funding to help
low and moderate income college students
go to school it's the president at a
time when 50 million Americans have no
health insurance community health
does would be cut by six hundred million
dollars said issue I work very very hard
on community health centers provide
access to primary health care dental
care low-cost prescription drugs and
mental health counseling for some 20
million Americans right now our hope was
to expand that to 40 million Americans
and when you do that you save money
because people do not end up in the
emergency room they do not end up in the
hospital sicker than they should have
been six hundred million dollars for
community health centers baka children's
health insurance program cut by 3.5
billion time when poverty is increasing
women infant and Children WIC program
nutrition program for low-income
pregnant women will be cut by 500
million at a time when we have such high
unemployment rates and when we want to
put Americans to work rebuilding our
crumbling infrastructure including our
rail system which is now fall behind
Europe Japan and even China federal
funding for high-speed rail will be
eliminated in the budget we're going to
be voting on very soon representing a
cut of 2.9 billion dollars public
transportation would be cut by nearly a
billion a twenty percent reduction mr.
president I know in Vermont and I expect
all over this country local communities
are struggling with their budgets police
departments are not getting the budgets
and the manpower that they need and yet
in this budget that will be voting on
local law enforcement funding would be
caught by 296 million dollars at a time
when homelessness is increasing when we
need more low-income housing public
housing would be cut by 605 million mr.
president that is the 2000 budget
agreement that was just reached a few
days ago and what is absolutely
incredible
about that budget is that deficit
reduction falls totally on the backs of
low and moderate income families on
people who will not be able to get
health care at community health centers
young people who will not be able to go
to college senior citizens who will not
be able to heat their homes in the
winter time that's where this budget is
balanced on the backs of the week the
vulnerable the children the elderly and
the poor and yet at the same time as the
wealthiest people are becoming wealthier
this budget does not ask for one penny
one penny from millionaires and
billionaires at a time when major
corporation after major corporation
enjoys huge tax loopholes so not only do
they avoid paying any federal income
taxes in many cases such as General
Electric they actually get a rebate from
the IRS this budget does not ask
corporate America to pay one penny more
in corporate income taxes and that's
where we are with the 2011 budget and
now we're looking in a short period of
time at the 2012 budget and mr.
president if you think this 2011 budget
is a moral and economic disgrace way to
you hear what this 2000 budget the
so-called Paul Ryan Tea Party budget
which as I understand it will be voted
upon in the house likely passing later
this beat this week that budget will
slash trillions of dollars from Medicare
converting Medicare into a voucher
program meaning that seniors will have
to pay substantially more for their
health care than they currently do and
mr. president the interesting question
that has not yet been answered
out this is if you are or will be when
this ryan budget we go into effect a
senior citizen living on fourteen or
fifteen thousand dollars a year of which
millions of seniors currently live how
are you going to be able to come up with
thousands and thousands of dollars to
pay for your cancer treatment or the
other problems that seeing the citizens
how you going to do it there is no money
available for you to do it so what
Ryan's budget does is the man that
low-income seniors pay for money with
money they don't have what happens I'm
not sure I've heard that answer if you
are all low-income senior citizen and
you're asked to come up with thousands
of dollars out of your pocket and you
don't have that money what do you do the
Ryan budget with savage medicaid
education the environment infrastructure
and other programs that tens of millions
of Americans depend upon but here is the
kicker we savage medicare medicaid
education and many other programs that
moderate and middle-class families
depend upon in order to give even more
tax breaks to the wealthiest people in
this country and to the largest
corporations after savaging health care
in America for middle income and
low-income families the Ryan budget
would reduce the tax rates for the
wealthiest people in this country from
thirty five percent to twenty-five
percent corporate income taxes the same
level 35 to 25 percent I suspect that
there are people who listening to me now
who just don't believe it they say you
come on you're not serious about it at a
time when the middle class is collapsing
in the rich are getting richer you're
not telling me that people in the house
are about to vote on a budget which will
give huge tax breaks to millionaires and
billionaires and to large corporations
and then cut back and throw millions
more off of health care you're not
really serious check it out I am serious
this is exactly what the Ryan Tea Party
budget
which will likely pass the house has in
mind so mr. president is I began saying
we are at a pivotal moment in a in the
history modern history of this country
and that is whether or not we move in a
sense into an oligarchic form of society
where a few people on top have
incredible amounts of wealth and
incredible amounts of political power
while the middle class disappears and
poverty increases that's where we are
right now and I would hope very much
that the American people engage in this
debate and to tell members of the Senate
to tell members of the house that it is
morally wrong and very poor economics to
cut back on programs desperately needed
by working families while give giving
huge tax breaks the people who
absolutely don't need that mr. president
with that I would yield the floor and
note the absence um tomorrow is
Washington journal more about